ah yes what we are going to do
um is uh talk about Halloween right now
because I went on Halloween with my son
uh and my wife and my uh brother Matt
Uncle Matt for Calvin and uh my dad and
my mom and we walked around this one
block where they shut it down and my son
was a purple people eater
one eye one-horned purple people eater
and uh and it was great because it was
the first real Halloween that my son was
kind of a uh
like a kid and not just like a
you know I don't want to say a blob but
when the kids are like one they're like
now they don't know anything they just
maybe make eye contact and [ __ ] but he
was like walking around he walked up to
people's doors one time he did it
completely by himself it was just really
[ __ ] cute and he was a purple people
eater and Kristen made the costume and
She's Crafty and she's my angel but
she's crafty dude and she uh she put it
together and that's just great man she
put it together and Calvin was happy and
he was so sweaty in his outfit but he
didn't want to take it off he wouldn't
take it off and I was a vampire and it's
just this block that uh that they shut
down and it was [ __ ] awesome man and
then and then I um
and then I uh I did uh I was this big
alien came came up to me and he was like
Chris Delia you know I was getting
recognized every now and then even
though I I was dressed I was I was a
vampire I look more like Chrisley than
Chris Lee because I was now I was in my
full form a real vampire I actually look
a vampire we put the blood down coming
down from my mouth like how I did in the
[ __ ] in our La in our old podcast in
the [ __ ] the golden hour it's called
now that we do over at uh uh what it
used to be the king of the stick in the
wing and uh and dude um yeah we uh this
big alien said hey what's up Chris and I
was like oh hey and he says it's me and
I couldn't see him and he pulled back
his alien costume and it was like a
screen and he smashed his face and he
said it's Mario and I was like who
and he says Mario Lopez and I was like
oh [ __ ] what's up you're here and he's
like yeah we [ __ ] live here and so uh
you know it was a star-studded event
whatever
it's a star threat event
it was me Mario Lopez and then
Frankenstein was there star starter
event I don't know if it was a real one
or not
um but yeah dude Halloween was beautiful
my dad and my mom had a great time my
mom was taking pictures of Calvin she
likes to take really close-up pictures
of Calvin it's crazy she likes to take
really really close-up pictures of
Calvin like of his face and it's so cute
but he doesn't say still and she always
gets blurry pictures and that's all good
dude that's something that would have
made me mad [ __ ] five years ago but
it doesn't now because I'm a changed man
you know I see her taking the pictures
I'm like my just [ __ ] zoom out a
little bit you can just cut it you can
just edit it towards closer it wasn't
about five years ago but now I'm a
transform it
thank you
know would have made me mad five years
ago and I'm looking at it I'm getting
heated now but also I simmer it because
I'm a changed man
uh
um
and then Calvin didn't say [ __ ] the
whole Halloween he was just walking
doing a job like focused and then he got
in the car wouldn't stop saying uh
my we got so much candy got so much
candy it was just really cute man really
[ __ ] cute
and then today after Halloween one of
the days after is one of the days after
Halloween and he was like let's look at
my candy and he pulled it up and he was
like should I eat this one and I let him
eat it and it was so cute dude he ate it
and he was like should I have enough
what what should I have a next should I
have another one because I was like
Calvin you should only eat one piece of
candy but um look I let him have a
smorgasbord candy Halloween night he ate
a lot I'm not like one of those parents
that's gonna be like okay enough but but
he had a lot and then the next day I was
like let's just have one and he was like
what should I eat next and he pulled out
Skittles and I'm like you're gonna
[ __ ] new first of all you're not
gonna like that song I'm Gonna choke on
it you don't know what it is so I pulled
out this bar this chocolate bar that had
coconut in it and I'm like I like that
one I was like Calvin we'll give you a
half of this okay
why don't we give you this is really
cute I was like I'll give you half of
one is that cool and we'll split it and
he said okay so I purposely split it to
where one side was a little bigger and I
said which one do you want and he picked
the big one so cute dude he picked the
big one he goes um you look at the ball
Adam boy goes this one pick the big one
thought he pulling over on me dude it
was so cute I was proud dude he took the
big piece and they put it in the mouth
and we realized he doesn't like coconut
so it's all good
it's all good he spit it out I picked it
up put it in my mouth I ate it I'm a
changed man would I ever take out
regurgitated food from someone's mouth
and eat it no but now my son made me a
bird
[Music]
I'll eat his food straight from his
mouth I'll give a [ __ ] dude I'm gangster
when it comes to that [ __ ] dude I'm
[ __ ] gangster when my son wants to
give me food that was ABC already been
chewed
so I [ __ ] your [ __ ] I'm gangster dude
crazy crazy
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]